hey youtubers is Charlie in korra book 4
footage just aired during a book 3 TV
trailer and there's a couple reasons why
i think it's legit mostly because a
similar thing happened before book 3
when an international trailer for book 2
featured book 3 footage so same drill
and it gives us a good idea for who the
villain might be we also got a release
date and details on the extras for the
book 3 DVD if you're just finding me for
the first time
yes core is over but I will be doing
bonus videos until book 4 gets here so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm even going to be doing Star Wars
rebels whenever that gets here I'll
explain at the end of the video so
important stuff first
kuvira in the book 4 footage we all knew
something was up with her nobody gets
that much screen time and the finale
without being important so the trailer
footage that we saw was actually not
from book 4 it was from a book 3 TV
trailer that was airing on Nicktoons I
know it's totally weird
it included scenes of kuvira with a very
evil look on her face addressing what
looks to be a Red Lotus council or at
least a council of officials it just
suggests a little bit about what the
plot and the time frame a book 4 might
be it seems like based on this it'll be
a continuation of the end of book 3 but
there won't be a giant jump in time and
see here's plot to throw the world that
the chaos will just be continuing so we
don't have any kind of confirmation on
what kuvira's backstory is other than
what soo-eun has told us but there are a
lot of really cool theories one of the
biggest is that she is the love child of
Zaheer and su yen if you look she does
resemble the two of them so it suggests
that she might have been raised in the
doctrine or the Red Lotus the timelines
on when she might have been born and
when su Yin and Sahir might have met our
little fuzzy so let's start with the
beginning of the Red Lotus it was formed
after the hundred year war by di Bao
after he got pissed that the White Lotus
got turned into what he saw as glorified
servants of the avatar if you remember
Jive a Grove in the spirit world was the
place where Korra confronted Zaheer
so I'm guessing that he originally used
it as a place to communicate with other
Red Lotus members like Zaheer used it or
just as a place to meditate and so here
continue the tradition you do have to
give him props though using the spirit
realm to Skype with your evil team
members is totally badass
eventually team Zaheer in analog are
brought into the order probably around
the same time there were cores age cut
to 13 years ago from the events on the
show say here in company are captured
trying to kidnap Korra and now that we
finally know
what's a year's final plan was to kill
Cora doesn't it sound so much sinister
they were gonna kidnap a little girl and
do that to her
that's dark even for legend of korra but
it doesn't seem like korra and kuvira
are too far apart in age so it's
possible that shortly after becoming
part of the Red Lotus is a here in suyun
met and eventually had a child or kuvira
could be the child of other Red Lotus
members it all stems from this picture
that was in soohyun's office of her and
her circus troupe it just looks like
this person is here so it's possible
they had some sort of relationship and
kuvira was the result of that regardless
of who became members of the Red Lotus
and who did not either way I think we
can surmise that the Red Lotus in the 13
years that Sahir's team was locked up
recruited a lot of new people there is a
lot of contradictory evidence for the
soo-eun Zaheer Red Lotus love child
theory but since soo-hyun shares a lot
of the anti-establishment beliefs that
Zaheer talked about it's possible she
was at one time associated with him and
then just didn't become part of the Red
Lotus I mean if she were a full-on Red
Lotus member if she'd drinking the
kool-aid she probably would've let Cora
die instead of pull that mercury out of
her there's also the possibility that
kuvira has absolutely no ties to anyone
on Team Corps or the Red Lotus she's a
completely new character who's not
trying to avenge some old family wound
and there's no guarantees that she's the
big villain she just could be working
for someone else that hasn't revealed
themselves yet there's still a whole lot
we don't know about book fourth story
I'm hoping that Bryke reveals some new
details at New York Comic Con in October
they are doing a core panel so if you're
going I recommend you sit in on it
they're usually pretty good about
teasing out new details and art and they
might even announce the official book
for premiere date there are some rumors
about that though right now supposedly
book 4 is airing in Australia during
January it doesn't guarantee that it's
gonna premiere in North America in
January or anywhere else in the world at
that time and just for reference book 3
is just starting in Australia in October
it's completely messed up and break
revealed in a recent interview that the
core of book 3 summer premiere was
completely unplanned like it was totally
turning on a dime until we hear
otherwise though just planned for a
january book 4 premiere January February
regardless of when they will be posting
episodes digitally in the same places
that they did during book 3 that's Nate
calm Amazon Google Play Store pretty
much everywhere but iTunes for some
strange reason I know a lot of you still
ask book 4
is not going to air on television in my
ear on Nicktoons after they premiered
digitally like sometimes way way down
the future in reruns but basically a new
episodes won't be on TV but there is
some good news the book 3 DBZ is coming
out December 2nd in the United States or
in North America not sure for
international release date but probably
not super long after that the bonus
features are pretty similar to the book
2 DVD the blu-ray has audio commentaries
for all 13 episodes and 13 animatics the
DVD is a little bit different it does
have all the animatics but it only has
four commentaries so obviously if you
want all the commentaries just get the
blu-ray I'll probably be giving away a
couple free copies as part of a giveaway
whenever we get closer to the release
date just to explain all the Star Wars
rebels stuff that I've been talking
about recently rebels is gonna be like
the new animated show that I do videos
for I'll be posting another big video
separately for that in a week or two so
look out for it since Lucasfilm is
Disney now they're airing new episodes
of rebels on Disney XD so if you want to
watch it you have to get that channel
the premiere is until October 13th but
on the 3rd they're doing a one-hour
special I will explain in a rebels bonus
video but Disney is basically creating a
Star Wars Cinematic Universe just like
Marvel so the TV shows the books the
comics will all influence what happens
in the movies and vice-versa the movies
will influence the other expanded
material when I say expanded I'm talking
about the new expanded material so like
all the new novels those will influence
what happens in the movies so watching
rebels will help you understand what's
going on in episode 7 and if you're not
convinced Dave felonious and charged her
everything on the show he did Clone Wars
and he used to be an animation director
for Mike and Brian during the avatar
last airbender days so he's keeping into
the family so you can kind of think of
watching rebels as supporting Mike and
Brian in a small way although
technically they have no affiliation and
don't forget if you didn't see my last
legend decor video studio Mir got four
new animated series greenlit by
DreamWorks Animation Mike and Brian
haven't announced any involvement with
that it'll be four separate shows with
78 episodes each so it's a huge deal but
right now you can click here to get my
book for predictions and click here to
learn all about Star Wars rebels thank
you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow advice
[Music]